c'est un homme en colère qui s'exprimait
hier sur les réseaux chillou des équipes
les gens qui mourront à la retire de
maintenant nous aurons aussi à cause de
vous
zinio où c'est le président ukrainien
vladmir zelensky s'emporte contre l'otan
les trente membres de l'alliance
viennent de rejeter la demande de kiev
créer une zone d'exclusion aérienne
interdire le survol de l'ukraine pour
éviter les bombardements de l'aviation
russe qui a la maîtrise du ciel comme le
montrent ces images fournies par l'armée
russe
nous ne sommes pas partie prenante de ce
conflit et nous avons la responsabilité
d'éviter l'escaladé de la jupe rennes
l'otan engagées depuis plusieurs
semaines dans des manoeuvres dans les
pays frontaliers veut à tout prix éviter
un risque de confrontation directe cette
new line ne pourrait être imposé que par
des avions de l'otan n'aurait l'un
directement un affrontement entre des
forces otanienne et des forces russes
c'est à dire pour la première fois un
affrontement direct entre l'otan et la
russie ce qui reviendrait à déclencher
la troisième guerre mondiale le
président céline ce qui a prévu de
s'exprimer cet après midi devant l'onu